(drums beating)
- Remember, attack together.
Every time I give you a three-four,
breathe on four, and attack on one.
I put so much love and
effort, sweat and blood,
and tears into this band program.
We are the best marching
band in the country.
(mellow music)
My name is Abraham Duffie Jr.
And I am the head drum major
for the Sonic Boom of the South.
We bring something that
no other band brings:
excitement, jaw-dropping,
in-your-face entertainment.
The Jackson State Drum Majors
are the heart of the band.
We are known for our showmanship,
but what a lot of people don't know
is we teach music to the band.
We lead the band, we help with formations,
and we also help guide the band.
(chanting)
And the beginning of August we practice
for about 20 hours a day
from 5 a.m. to 12 a.m. in the morning.
You really just have
to find time to sleep.
(chanting)
- Exercise!
(upbeat music)
- Not only is it physical training,
it's also mental and
emotional training as well
that's needed in order
to be a part of a program
of our caliber.
- What goes on is lot of
playing, a lot of playing,
and a lot of playing.
And also marching.
Marching, marching, marching, marching.
Being in physical shape
gives you endurance.
It helps you play better
and perform better
and also gives you muscle memory.
(drums beating)
(band music playing)
This is my fourth and
final year as Drum Major.
My hope for the future of the band
is to just excel, be better
than the bands before them,
be better musicians.
Just to finally be at
the end is bittersweet,
but I am going to leave
and never look back,
because I know I made my mark.
(applause)